what I think about it's like if you go
back to like cavemen days yeah
do animals rape like monkeys and
gorillas and stuff because you know the
male penis is is made like a pump so
that you [ __ ] and you suck the all the
jizz out so that your jizz can get in I
swear to God I shot that head
cuz it sucks out the jail as if witches
well say their science alert I love in
the scenario this rape is so prevalent
that it's just like sucking out the
other guys Cheers this is a bad image oh
I see what you're saying but this what
you're saying is to suck up the juice
cuz the penis had is like a pump right I
could okay let's say you and I were
gonna raping other world raping of the
less humans have raped enough that our
dicks have evolved to suck other
people's cheese out of the vagina oh my
god like that's right that's what the
penis head is it sucks out I swear to
God but another theory is that villages
back when we were hunter-gatherers they
would all [ __ ] way more monogamy wasn't
a thing where you would have a village
of people and and a bunch of dudes would
have sex with a woman and they would all
raise the child together so biologically
what you were competing with all these
other guys you were all having sex but
you didn't care about whose child it was
it was that it was the villages child
whoa that they used to do it then like
yeah when they were hunter get when we
look at gatherer yeah would you have
been okay I would have been a gathering
berries I'll be weaving guys I'd be
looking for roots right we're gonna go
hunt bison I'd be like go ahead I'm good
yeah right I dream of being together to
this day yeah me too I wish I will you
would you're a hundred
you're hungry yeah how about you Gil I'm
gonna pick berries yeah very good very
very good bear this is very progressive
gender roles I know I'm not making up a
spear yeah I'm not doing any of that so
can I just say this out loud I never
said this out loud oh I'm not a hero I'm
a coward I don't say that I'm like I'm
just a coward if I ever got drafted to
war I'll tell you right now I will go to
prison not because I'm some great
conscientious objector yes a coward or
I'll go to I just know like if they said
you're drafting and crafting you I would
just tell everyone okay guys
that means I'm dead so I will say my
goodbyes no I will go well this guy I'll
gonna tell everyone cool George I'm
going to the war so I'm done I'm gonna
die
whatever said doesn't even I would be
you would be confirmed you would just be
like that's what's happening yeah I
would just go I'm gonna die and that's
how you know how fortunate I feel like
the fact that we belong to a generation
that never got drafted for war is one of
the greatest treats of all generations
to ever exist on this whole planet in
human history how this until we never
had to fight a war
yeah I mean well it's true who are
fighting wars volunteer for exactly not
volunteer I mean you had to serve in the
military right two years he almost did
two in Israel but he got out of it in
Korea they have it yes sir of like two
or three years five years no but in
Israel you move they're like well you
gets a little hairy over there yeah did
you actually see combat when you did it
oh no only only once cuz I wanted to ask
them to take me with them yeah she's a
hunter they shot at yeah they shot at
you yeah oh my house we scared I was
pretty weird yeah we weren't we were in
the gym she was an armored driving oh my
god I love
commanders in there like a really risky
area yeah
and then there was like it right here no
oh my god and did you smile like you're
smiling now what do you do I'm you if
you cut in the past and we saw that and
she was doing that that would be the
funniest thing I've ever seen Wow
you know when I went to Israel they took
us to a port like more the people that
UN whatever the hats what are they
called what the has seats
no there was like the people that are
there were the blue hats or something
the religious Jews no they're like UN
yeah Oh like you win that you win
whether it's a religious thing or they
know that you know there were people
that um were Israeli but they were just
guarding the border or something okay
and we went to this area and you could
from the distance here machine guns and
things being blown up yeah I mean just
closest yeah when I was there there was
like for about a month
there was a daily Rockets coming up from
Gaza and we were living at Tel view and
[ __ ] air sirens going out oh and we
have to take cover it was really unusual
because usually they they didn't reach
Tel Aviv before it was the first time
they reached oh my god so it was unusual
for people in Tel Aviv to experience
that
[Music]